Few Hollywood films have caused as much controversy
as The Exorcist.
Its theatrical release in 1973 terrified and
outraged audiences with a grotesque tale of
demonic possession, and despite barely escaping
an adult rating, it made history by becoming the
first horror film to earn a Best Picture Oscar
nomination.
It's still considered one of the scariest
movies ever made, but the intrigue surrounding
The Exorcist isn't limited to its shock value.
In fact, some of the most compelling aspects
of the movie come from behind the scenes.
Here are some lesser-known facts about the
classic that's been "turning heads" for over
40 years.
“Damien!”
Real life basis
Believe it or not, some of the aspects of
The Exorcist were inspired by real events.
The film is based on William Peter Blatty's
novel of the same name, which drew from accounts
of an actual exorcism.
According to the New York Post, most of the
source material for the book was culled from
the journals of Jesuit priests who documented
an exhausting battery of rituals they performed
on a young boy named "Roland Doe" in 1949.
These priests claimed to have witnessed the
boy speaking in tongues, mysterious skin markings
spelling the words "hell" and "evil," the
violent shaking of the boy's mattress, and
the breaking of hospital restraints and a
priest's nose, to name a few.
Some of the claims are admittedly embellished
in Blatty's novel and the film adaptation
— nobody spewed a bunch of green vomit,
for example — but still, that's pretty creepy.
Church support
It may come as a surprise that many officials
of the Catholic Church were completely behind
the film's release.
Not only did it drum up plenty of interest
in Catholic tradition, it highlighted Catholic
priests as heroes performing a time-honored
ritual, even if that ritual got a little repetitive.
"The power of Christ compels you!
The power of Christ compels you!
The power of…”
The story goes that one official even dug
up some classified documents for The Exorcist.
While doing research for the film, director
William Friedkin met with the president of
the Jesuit Georgetown University, who supposedly
handed him a folder containing eyewitness
accounts of the 1949 exorcism.
Cursed production
The production of The Exorcist was riddled
with complications and tragedy.
Early in production, the set depicting the
home of the MacNeill family mysteriously caught
fire, delaying filming.
Even more mysterious: the set for Regan's
room, in which the exorcisms would be filmed,
remained completely undamaged.
Many of the cast and crew experienced tragedies,
too.
Linda Blair's grandmother, Max Von Sydow's
brother, and two of the film's actors passed away
suddenly during the course of production,
and Jason Miller's son was nearly killed in
a freak motorcycle accident.
And then there were the accidents on set.
Ellen Burstyn sustained a spinal injury while
filming a violent possession scene, which
reportedly still bothers her today.
As the unexpected problems piled up, the production
extended well past its projected deadline.
Friedkin even had the set blessed by a priest.
Maybe he should have gone for an exorcism
while he was at it.
Wild release
You'd have to be pretty crazy to send
threats to a teenage girl, but that's exactly
what some religious folks did to Linda Blair.
After the film was released in theaters, hate
mail poured in accusing Blair of "glorifying
Satan."
Warner Bros. had go so far as to hire bodyguards
to protect her after the film was released.
And that's not the only bizarre incident surrounding
the theatrical release of the film.
A man fell and broke his jaw during a screening,
claiming the film's subliminal effects caused
him to faint.
He sued the studio and they settled out of
court.
This was just one of countless reports of
paramedics being called to theaters to treat
terrified moviegoers for hysterics.
Anonymous demon
The demon that possesses Regan is called Pazuzu,
but that name is never mentioned in the original
film, despite being in both the book and the
production script.
Pazuzu is a real-ish demon — he's based
on a mythological Babylonian figure, a king
of demon winds, comprised of human and animal
parts.
Father Merrin finds an artifact in the desert
at the beginning of the film that is supposed
to be a portion of a Pazuzu statue.
While the demon is seen, it wouldn't be named
outright until the 1977 sequel The Exorcist
II: The Heretic.
Low-budget effects
The Exorcist may have been unlike anything
ever seen at the time, but Friedkin had to
rely on some pretty everyday effects to create
the movie.
He reportedly fired a gun before takes to
terrify the cast.
Many scenes were shot in freezing temperatures
to maximize the effect of actors' breath and
discomfort on film.
That vomit?
Thick split pea soup.
The sound of Regan projectile vomiting was
produced by a demonic voice actress, who regurgitated
mushy apple and raw egg.
And the creepy sound of Regan's head turning
was nothing more than the sound of a leather
wallet being twisted in front of a microphone.
It's so simple it's evil.
Not a horror movie
According to Friedkin, all these years of
terror might have been a case of mistaken
intention.
He told The Hollywood Reporter:
"I thought it was a film about the mystery
of faith...but I didn't set out to make a
horror film...but by now, I have accepted
that it is."
That's a noble point of view, but the Exorcist
sequels and prequels have kept the franchise
pretty squarely in genre film territory.
That's all fine as long we we don't have to
watch anymore vomit geysers.
[Laughter]
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!